[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's nick wright one of our favorites
first thing first co-host on fox sports
one and he joins us
from his car where are you right now
i'm outside of the costco dan waiting
for some new tires my friend that's what
i'm doing uh
but you know what i'll always make time
for you i appreciate it never say no uh
can i tell you a story story from
married life that has put me in this
position
sure
okay
so um as you can tell and your viewers
can tell just from this little snapshot
i obviously have a very fine luxury
vehicle and i bought it recently
and about a month ago my wife said we
need new tires
like no we don't
just got the car a year ago definitely
don't need new tires she said we need
new tires and i you know i said okay i'm
not
i don't know how to say this you know my
i should be i kind of felt like you know
what that's my territory this is the car
this is the tires like i know that's
anachronistic but i'm just being honest
with you my friend
so
you know two weeks later she and i are
driving doing some christmas shopping
west side highway in manhattan
i can feel it
flat tire
and i swear dan i tried to ignore it i
tried to just pretend it did wasn't
happening and my wife says to me she
says
what's wrong with the car and i again i
don't know what my plan was i said nope
she looks she looks out the window she
said pieces of the tire are flying off
[Laughter]
so i'm on the west side highway i find
there's no good place to pull over i
pull over she's like i'm calling triple
a i'm like no you're not i'm doing this
myself i'm fixing this tire
so i change the tire do that so like i
told you we need new tires i'm like yes
baby you're right so that day
you know buy them on costco.com shout
out to them set the appointment
dan
sunday i'm sitting there watching
football upset because my chiefs have
lost my wife is out with my youngest
daughter i get a phone call and i don't
believe in premonitions but as soon as
the phone rang i was like jesus christ i
bet we have another flat tire
she calls me
it's raining
me and your daughter are on the side of
the highway
another flat
don't spare
that's what you have triple a for nick
yeah you know what back when i was a kid
when men were men dan we did that stuff
ourselves yeah so new tires
new tires okay wait a minute hold on
here who believes that nick wright
changed the tire on your video on it
you have video what are you talking
about yeah because my wife thought i was
gonna fail my wife thought i was gonna
fail
uh you are a lug nut um well thanks for
joining us here where do you want to
start do you want to start with aaron
rodgers is a jerk baker mayfield
shutting it down why now not last week
jim harbaugh's story
you pick let's start with aaron rodgers
let's start with aaron rodgers because
uh that that the hub arcish interview
happened on the parkinson spiegel show
on 670 the score and i'm not sure if
you're familiar with danny perkins but
i've known him for 20 years he and i did
college radio together i think he's the
best local talk radio host in america on
the sports scene so i'd like to start
there give him a shout out here's the
thing
i think aaron rodgers the mvp
i also think
this idea the unanimous twitter response
was oh my god this is why media
shouldn't have votes oh my god they you
know the so before dan the woke mob
comes to put poor hub arcish in a cancel
culture casket let me say this
the line of reasoning that hobarticus
used to not vote for aaron rodgers is
used all the time in mvp discussions i
had to hear about how brady why is brady
the mvp even when he doesn't have the
numbers oh my he brought his team
together
he helped build the roster he held off
season activities we always use not just
the numbers to make or not make mvp
cases so
how orcish feels aaron rodgers you know
non-number stuff works against him i
agree it works against him it's just
it's to me it doesn't work against him
enough like yes he maybe cost him the
week one game with the distractions and
play terribly certainly cost him the
chiefs game but despite that they're
still the one seat so i don't so i i
don't think have arkish's argument is a
ludicrous one i just think roger's on
field excellence and the packers
excellence is enough to overcome it but
i think it's totally fair to say how
good of a teammate are you how much of a
distraction do you cause in a d and
weigh that as part of the mvp discussion
i think if he had chosen different words
then people would have had a different
reaction if you say that he's you know
the biggest jerk or whatever you can say
look he was a distraction cost his team
week one and we could argue that but i
think there's validity there what
happened with kansas city and at the
time i said on the show this will be
held against aaron rodgers in the mvp
race it's going it should yes and it
should and i have no problem with that i
just think that the language or it felt
like hey here's a bears guy
and he's going in on a chicago radio
station uh in a a season where rogers
says i still own you
and you're playing to your audience a
little bit there i i think if the
language was a little
softer with it that hub could have
gotten his argument through and more
people would have understood it and said
yes you're right
i also think it does reveal this part of
it
i think how many people vote for the
heisman trophy like i assume mclovin
even though he's gone now i think he got
a heisman trophy vote when he left like
that was part of the package like i
think a thousand people vote for that
yeah i think that's too many i think 50
nfl mvp voters when they only submit one
name not even a full ballot that's
probably too few
like yeah i think the nba probably has
it right a hundred voters
and you submit a one through five
that way
the margin for error is to me
it's not as likely to get screwed up by
a few people
and so i think that maybe you could look
at it that way but i i i think the media
should still vote on these things i
don't think it's perfect but i think
it's better than algorithms and it's
certainly certainly better than players
who are going to have their own biases
there we're talking to nick wright first
things first and uh also a part-time
mechanic he'll uh work in the pits
during the nascar season as well no only
european cars dan oh
so
f1 yeah exactly me and lewis hamilton oh
i like that
uh do you believe that jim harbaugh is
considering
might be interested in returning to the
nfl
you know so one of my best friends i'm
gonna give another shout out you got a
lot of friends
this guy does you danny perkins and
laszlo lazlo does rock radio
in uh kansas city are actually
nationwide and he's a die hard michigan
fan okay and he said this to me a month
ago and i thought he was full of it he
goes doesn't it feel like the ultimate
harbaugh move to finally beat ohio state
to finally win the big ten and then say
deuces you guys cut my pay you guys made
me eat it so i've done i've come i've
done what i said i was gonna do i've
done it now i'm out and when he said it
i thought he was nuts
but
it seems reasonable and
while i think there is going to be a
chilling effect on hiring college
coaches harbaugh might be the exception
there because he already had great
success in the nfl
i think there's something to it i
wondered if he lost to ohio state
was was he then gonna leave and go to
the chicago bears um
now you win and and i also find the
reaction to the win against ohio state
and the blowout loss against georgia
very interesting and very telling in ann
arbor because it's we beat ohio state
yeah but you got blown out embarrassed
against georgia yeah but we beat ohio
state
if it was reversed ohio state fans yeah
we beat michigan but man we got we got
some issues we got blown out by georgia
i don't know what michigan's tolerance
level is that as you move forward
you're never going to out recruit ohio
state well that's not going to listen
the thing is
and you know this better than me but
michigan and ohio state are rivals
but they are not in the same class
historically in college football like
what does michigan have one championship
in the last what 60 years or something i
don't know i don't know the numbers i
just know you know i obviously used to
do the show with chris carter who's the
ohio state guy and whenever this would
come up he would show me side by side
big ten titles national championship
like ohio state
is historically a far better program
than michigan
and so
to me there is it's not alabama auburn
but it's probably closer to alabama
auburn than people think it is
um
the kyrie situation i know you've been
close to it with uh
the nets and now he's coming back but
then he can't play home games here
uh and and you know the vaccine mandate
city by city it seems very fluid right
now but
what
is that your tire guy right there yeah
dan i'm gonna have to take this on the
show on the road so you keep asking me
about kyrie oh okay
okay go ahead there's gonna be a little
rain here buddy but we can make it
through i am here for you damn patrick
uh kyrie
so yeah kyrie
how do you think this plays out with uh
the nets and kyrie terribly it's an
awful idea i can't believe they're doing
it everyone agreed it was a terrible
idea then the net said they were doing
it and so people are pretending it can
work it can't work
here's the only way it could work dan
and i'm gonna try to get out of the rain
for your wonderful viewers and listeners
um
if they made him the sixth man
if they made him the sixth man i think
that could work if they were like we
need katie and harden with as many
critical minutes together but you can
add some punch off the bench in road
games fine but they're not going to do
that
so i think the more interesting question
is this if they're going to go along
with this charade that this actually can
work shouldn't they intentionally make
sure they're no better than the fifth
seed
if their argument is we are better with
all three of them then don't you want to
start
every playoff series with two games with
all three of them and any potential game
seven have all three of them it's not
like oh we're gonna miss out on the
amazing home court advantage of barclays
they were chanting for john moran mvp at
barclays a couple days
so
i think i think if they're gonna do this
but that's why i don't think it'll work
because it's like winning is good but
you know what's also good losing
losing's good too i think the whole
thing is insane yeah i just think it's
an insane idea
and i don't think a serious organization
would engage in it that's what i think
uh before i let you go and you attend to
your tires uh baker mayfield situation i
i don't know why he's shutting it down
now didn't shut it down before
and it feels like he said i'm not gonna
play i'm gonna have surgery and then the
browns have to kind of acquiesce and say
yes he's shutting it down
and mike what what happened why not play
this next week against your hated rivals
the cincinnati bengals
i don't know and by the way the one team
baker has owned in his career cincinnati
his numbers against cincinnati are
amazing is everyone else not great
uh i think he's handled this whole thing
terribly
i think that if he shut it down he would
still probably not shut it down but if
he would have gotten surgery when he
needed it three months ago missed five
weeks come back healthy maybe he gets a
contract i also think and this is the
point i made on the show the other day
uh and i'll make it again here we always
hear about all these bet on yourself
success stories
and that's because the people who bet on
themselves and lose don't tell their
stories they're just sad
baker mayfield is a great example of bet
on yourself not being a great idea
always if he would have taken the
brown's final contract offer this off
season call it 30 million a year with 60
million guaranteed not only does he then
have
60 million guaranteed i bet he does have
the surgery i bet the franchise makes
him yeah i bet they're like three weeks
in we have a four-year investment in you
you have nothing else to prove you want
to play off game last year to have the
surgery come back at week eight and see
what you can do
instead he tried to gut through it he is
not talented enough to overcome
a physical injury when physicality is
already his biggest limitation and
instead i mean he won the first playoff
game that franchise has won in 26 years
first playoff appearance in 18 years
first winning season in a dozen years
and now it's a legitimate conversation
like um should they bring in tyler
huntley like it is crazy
how fast and how quickly it has fallen
for baker yeah
are you getting snow tires or all-season
tires
you know dan again i don't want to you
know for the third time on the show to
talk about what a nice car i have but
these types of vehicles you like to have
different seasonal tires you know what i
mean you like to have certain for the
winter certain for the summer certain
that can handle salt certainly can't so
okay you know that's what i'm doing
right now my friend okay i'd still like
to see the video of you changing yeah as
a journalist of you changing the tire
okay you know what you're also going to
see in that video because i am shirtless
in that video
you're going to say
my guy nick right he's a little more
rocked up
you're going to say my god now this guy
hides it well in the suit now i really
need to see it
okay i'll text it to you shirtless
winter i love it
it's so hot listen man a man of all
seasons tires
[Laughter]
thank you nick
see ya nick wright first things first
ah that's interesting
now i can't get that image of nick
wright shirtless out there changing his
tire in winter in new york